tout ce qui touche à l'eau il accelle et
de suite il est de suite
performant il a navigué dans toutes les
mers du monde il a navigué à jaose qui
est la plus grosse vague une des grosse
vague
mondiale bon il a navigué à Belara aussi
dans le sud de la France du côté de
barit O c'est une très très grosse
vague
on voit à peine derrière la vague mais
j'ai pas eu peur j'ai pas eu peur je
crois que lui il a pas eu peur mais
MarieClaire elle avait peur oui oui elle
le disait pas trop mais elle avait
peur j'ai rarement peur c'est vrai que
je suis quand même quelqu'un qui calcule
énormément et qui va savoir si c'est
possible ou pas possible si c'est
dangereux si je suis capable après des
des conditions extrêmes j'en ai eu
énormément mais j'en ai jamais eu ou je
suis jamais je me suis dit c'est pas
possible je peux pas y
aller sa vie c'est ça il il a pas Panau
qu' dit depisici je passe pas DEP depici
c'est pas par moi tout les contraire il
est panneau ici voudrait les dépasser
voudrait aller plus loin plus rapidement
plus tout on était jamais allé aussi
vite en planche à voie le record absolu
de vitesse a été battu hier après midi
par le Français Antoine Alb sainmie de
la mer il a dépassé les 90 km he
détrenant ainsi un Irlandais détenteur
du titre à cette vitesse là on ne
navigue quasiment plus on
vole ce que je dis toujours c'est que la
sensation de vitesse en windsurf ne
ressemble à rien d'autre aller à 30 nud
sur une planche à voile en ressenti ça
revient à faire du 200 km en
voiture tu cours contre le temps contre
toimême et contre les
sa vole de l'eau qui s'envole de l'eau
salée le soleil qui burine et puis cette
force deent qui vous propulse en avant
ça c'est un truc exceptionnel qu'on a
pas dans d'autres sports de vitesse donc
la vitesse est vraiment un excitant en
fait le canal de ludérit c'est en amiie
c'est un canal qui a été creusé
spécialement pour les records du monde
de vitesse j suis allé deux fois pour
améliorer m
rec que tu ressens sur le canal à 100
km/ he c'est de la pure
adrénaline c'est une sensation
incroyable et quand tu arrives enfin au
bout du canal et que tu te rends compte
que tu as atteint cette vitesse maximale
tu es tellement bon que tu as juste
envie d'y
[Musique]
retourner tu fais pas une tentative le
vent c'est très aléatoire
[Musique]
en fonction de l' du vent il peut avoir
plein de vaguou alors ça peut être
complètement
PL c'est pour ça qu'il faut beaucoup
d'expérience et plein de tentativ pour
obtenir le
parfa c'est un engagement physique parce
que le canal de c'est une piste noire
qui tu pars dans le vide une erreur
peutre
fatale les chutes sont très
[Musique]
impressionnantes
pour savoir ce que ça représente vous
prenez votre voiture vous roulez à 90
vous ouvrez la portière et vous
sautez mais dans le run tuas pas de
peur si tu as peur pendant le R de
vitesse déjà sur les
freins maisit parce va chercher ça ça de
dépasser 2015 j'ai péris
mon de 539 27 et pour l'instant personne
n'a
[Musique]
fait j'ai battu le record ce jourlà 17
fois
c'est s fait cette chasse au record
c'est qu' il a ça dans la peau c'est
tout
on dit toujours que la chance sourit aux
audacieux et c'est vrai et Antoine a
tenté sa chance en amibi il est arrivé
complètement préparé physiquement
matériellement avec les bons outils et
il a explosé le record donc
chapeau